(upbeat music)
- Oh shit I'm late.
Up, up, up, let's go.
C'mon we didn't even
check your homework folder
this weekend, oh my God.
Sweetheart you have a
science project due today.
Why didn't you tell me this?
How are we supposed to get this done?
- [Voiceover] Mom.
- Oh my God, this is not
that bad, I can fix this.
Sweetheart I'll give you a dollar
if you find mommy's sunglasses.
- Oh thanks, thank you so
much for making me coffee
and leaving me some, oh, you're welcome.
Oh shit I forgot bread.
Sweetheart I'm gonna
pack you some leftovers.
Really yummy leftovers okay?
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- God what is that?
Oh God.
Hey honey, does mold count
as a science experiment?
This is your science project.
Alright, got your backpack, purse, phone.
Alright sweetheart get your shoes on,
I'm gonna load the car,
we're getting Starbucks for breakfast.
Ya-hoo, mommy needs her coffee.
Hurry up with those shoes, we're late.
Just kidding, mommy forgot her pants.
- Nice outfit.
- Oh thanks Karen, nice face lift.
- Oh.
(upbeat music)